good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we told you earlier in
the week about how the left is very mad
in fact trying to shut down a site
called libs of tick tock why are they so
mad at libs of tick tock well here's one
of the reasons over the past half year
or so video after video has appeared on
social media showing school teachers
bragging enthusiastically about how they
push their personal sexual politics
often weird and gruesome sexual politics
on the small children they're supposed
to be teaching now the students in
question are not teenagers they're
kindergartners first graders kids who
have no perspective on life and no power
to fight back
so many parents saw these videos in some
cases on libs of tick tock and they were
shocked they had no idea that anything
like this was happening in the classroom
having some purple-haired loser in a
nose ring convinced her six-year-old to
get a sex change is not why most people
send their children to school
so they complained the parents did and
across the country republican
officeholders responded by promising to
do something about this
they made outrage noises but then in
very short order they moved on to
talking about ukraine which is what they
really care about not you
in the end only one state really did
anything about this that would be the
state of florida under ron desantis
several weeks ago the florida
legislature passed a law banning
teachers from bragging about their own
sex lives to small children
now news reporters went crazy they
described this legislation as the don't
say gay bill but as always that was a
lie this bill didn't even mention the
word gay nothing to do with gays
florida voters seem to know that
intuitively even most democrats in
florida supported this law the polling
firm public opinion strategies found out
why they do quote fully two-thirds of
voters believe it is inappropriate for
teachers or school personnel to discuss
gender identity with children in
kindergarten through third grade well of
course it is
everyone thinks that so if there was
ever a law that accurately reflected
public opinion which should matter in a
democracy this was the law
but across the country in the state of
california bob iger was watching and bob
ogger didn't like it
bob iger is the 71 year old former head
of disney he's a bundler for hillary
clinton
he's got some free time and strong
political view so he promptly tweeted
the florida law was immoral somehow
in an interview later with cnn with
chris wallace iger explained that
preventing teachers from promoting
gender reassignment surgery to
kindergartners was quote harmful to
children iger never explained how this
was harmful but it didn't matter over at
disney headquarters his remarks caused
huge problems for the company's new ceo
bob chapic
now by all accounts bob chapic is not
especially political he's not an
activist he's a marketing guy
so his first instinct was not to get
involved not to comment on what was
happening in florida and that seemed
wise given how much at stake disney has
in florida they own a theme park in
orlando you may have heard that's an
enormous physical asset that cannot be
loaded on a truck and move so maybe
don't mess with florida as chapic put it
in a memo quote corporate statements do
very little to change outcomes or mines
he wrote that on march 7th explaining
why disney planned to take a pass on
this controversy because they make
movies not laws
but bob chapic's employees had other
ideas
whipped into a frenzy by their former
boss bob iger disney staffers demanded
action immediately and then because he
is weak and not especially bright bob
chapic caved to their demands he agreed
to hold a town hall with the grieve
disney employees who wanted him somehow
to take control of the florida
legislature
here's how that went i hope you've all
read my most recent note in which i
pledged to be a better ally for the
lgbtq plus community
apologize for not being the ally that
you needed me to be
and committed to ensuring that our
company lives up to its values
your words have made a real impact on me
i understand that we've made mistakes
and the pain that those mistakes have
caused and i know that our silence
wasn't just about the bill in florida
but about every time an individual or
institution that should have stood up
for this community did not i want to
thank the
lgbtqia plus advisory council
hey bob what is lgbtqia
stand for you're no freaking clue that's
not the interesting part the interesting
part of what you just heard was your
words have made a real impact on me
in other words you now have full control
over my entire central nervous system
you own my brain do with me what you
will
and they did
bob chapic soon reversed his position
disney's position completely going
forward not only did the disney
corporation fervently disagree with the
law the florida legislature had passed
according to bob chapic disney had
decided to override the expressed will
of florida's voters and overturn that
law quote
our goal as a company said bob chapic is
for this law to be repealed by the
legislature or struck down in the courts
and we remain committed to supporting
the national and state organizations
working to achieve that
whoa
what
you thought it was an entertainment
company but no
from its headquarters in los angeles the
disney corporation had now decided it
runs the state of florida
so for people who want to defend
democracy which is a system in which
voters get to govern themselves this was
quite a departure
this is oligarchy corporate ceos
deciding what the laws should be
yeah
that's their new position but in the
meantime disney employees set about
trying to undermine the intent of
florida's law if teachers could no
longer promote transgenderism to
kindergarteners disney plan to step into
the breach and do it themselves here's
internal footage from disney obtained by
journalist chris ruffo
last summer we removed all of the
gendered greetings in relationship to
our life skills so we no longer say
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls um
we we've trained we provided training
for all of our our cast members in
relationship to that so now they know
it's it's hello everyone or hello
friends
oh so it's no more boys and girls disney
world is now non-binary
okay
that's the diversity of inclusion lady
you're not surprised what is surprising
is that the head of a publicly held
company like disney would announce in
public
that he's in charge of a state that we
thought was run by the voters of that
state
well in florida
ron desantis noticed this he's the
elected governor and he decided to find
out how does the system work he decided
to test democracy so during a special
session of the florida legislature this
week desantis led an effort to strip
disney of what turned out to be a
remarkable set of special perks that
company had enjoyed for more than 50
years you are not treated like disney is
treated in florida you have never been
treated that well
so after the special session no more
will disney world operate as its own
independent country within the state of
florida yes that's how they were
governed by themselves and now going
forward disney is going to have to pay
its taxes oh wow just like everybody
else
now if you've lived in this country for
more than say five years ask yourself
what's the political party that has
always told you big companies should pay
their taxes corporate tax breaks are bad
well of course that's always been the
democratic party
so you would imagine the democrats in
florida would applaud a move like this
when was the last time you heard
liberals complain about stripping tax
breaks from big business never before in
history it's never happened and yet it
just did happen
these are democrats in the florida
legislature notice they are in the verge
of tears as they learn that the disney
corporation might have to pay taxes
the clerk will unlock the machine and
members will
proceed to vote
[Applause]
clerk will lock the machine now it's a
vote 68 years 38 days mr speaker show
the bill passes
you may have sensed that the democratic
party over the last decade or so
has been captured by corporate interests
but you never thought that you would
hear on the floor of a state legislature
democrats scream with anguish at the
idea that a big company might have to
pay its taxes
unbelievable
but now very clear
what's going on here well a lot of
things here's one disney spends millions
of dollars electing lawmakers in the
state of florida but those lawmakers
couldn't do their job in this case they
couldn't act on disney's behalf the law
passed and desantis signed it into law
this afternoon and that's going to cost
the disney corporation a ton of money
which in turn may mean less money for
the florida democrats you just saw
shrieking in the video so there was some
self-interest involved here but it
wasn't just that because it wasn't just
democratic office holders who were upset
by the idea that an elected governor
might be more powerful than an unelected
corporation headquartered across the
continent the media were very upset too
very upset watch this
if ron desantis could pass an
anti-muslim bill for the state of
florida he would if he could pass an
anti-crt if he could say it's illegal to
say you're black i'm pretty sure the guy
would try it i mean look desantis has
this is a playbook out of putin and we
saw where this goes it's very soviet and
it's weird how republicans they keep
tacking back to the old soviet union and
they seem to want to mimic the things uh
that the new soviet union meaning
vladimir putin is doing and even in our
conversations about desantis it's about
how well they're serving him the the
truth is
dehumanization
as a tactic for politics is from war
dehumanization is a it's a it's a tactic
it's being used right now
the russians get their soldiers
to rape children by dehumanizing them
dehumanization as a practice is a tactic
of war
so just to be clear and by the way
there's clearly some kind of inverse iq
test going on in the hiring department
over at msnbc but here are the new rules
if you would like a big publicly held
corporation to pay its taxes then you're
a child rapist obviously you're a racist
you're like putin which means you're a
fascist but you know what else you are
according to joy reid
your communist ron desantis is quote
taking us back to the soviet union
you're a communist
if you want the company to pay its taxes
now joyride went to harvard so we're not
going to disagree with her but we did
feel a moral obligation to check that
fact because it's a heavy claim
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight